I'm not sure there was any one thing in
my childhood that made me think I could
have an impact it was a series of you
know little events and it was the way my
parents raised me particularly to do the
right thing even when nobody was looking
it's sort of easy to do the right thing
if people are watching you right because
you don't want to look awful but my
father in particular helped me really
understand that what matters is that you
do the right thing all the time even
when nobody's looking he defended the
the poor he grew up very poor during the
Great Depression in the US and he was
treated badly because he was very poor
so he grew up with a very strong
disregard for the wealthy who oppressed
the poor the end that certainly sunk in
somewhere my oldest brother was born
deaf and there were a couple of
neighborhood boys who were bullies and
took particular joy in tormenting my
brother because he couldn't you know
hear them and he there was nothing wrong
with his vocal cords so he could make
sounds but they were very bizarre
sounding because of course he didn't
have any sense of what you know how
sound was modulated in the hearing world
so they really liked torturing him you
know by being mean and listening to the
sounds he would make and there were a
couple of times that I'm three years
younger than my brother Steve
that I tried to go after the bullies and
beat them up and they were quite a bit
older and you know I was so stupid or
naive at the time I actually thought if
I caught them I could beat them up I
would have been the one beat up I think
out of the combination of my dad my
mother I was supporting what we all
chose to do in life and my father's very
strong feeling that he didn't care what
other people thought about his opinions
and I certainly have that I don't care
if you don't agree with me that's your
business but I don't care what you think
about what I think and what I do and I
got that from dad and then trying to
defend my brother I think morphed into
trying to defend others in grade school
who wouldn't speak up and that made me
mad because they could speak you know
why wouldn't they and then Vietnam
happened and I protested Vietnam and it
just shattered my image of the mythology
of great peaceful America and it led me
ultimately on the path to trying to stop
US military intervention in Central
America and then just overall wanting to
try to mitigate the impact of war in one
way or the other and my belief that by
removing weapons systems by getting the
public to talk about weapons and why we
want to get rid of them is a
contribution to peace